our top story at the bottom of the hour
President Trump is defending his support
for arming school teachers in the wake
of last week's massacre in Florida but
some schools are not waiting for another
disaster to act of course my Matt Finch
owes us tonight they're already giving
their teachers the means to defend
themselves and their students two school
districts near Dayton Ohio have a
confidential team of teachers and staff
trained to fire back at an active
shooter our staff members for training
to go to the threat and address the
threat not to run away the schools take
measures to conceal the guns that are
hidden in biometric or numeric safes
that can be opened only by staff on the
armed response team each member is
vetted by the district must have a
license to carry and attend monthly
rigorous training all the first
responder team members have access to
these as well
many students seem to support the idea
of their teachers being armed to have
people inside the school who know what
they're doing and who can protect us I
think that's amazing and I don't really
think there's any room for complaints
when we're inside those four walls there
are safety that's our safety for today
however both districts face opposition
lots of teachers teach let the law
enforcement take care of the laws the
Sydney Police Chief says he's not
against the armed teachers but worries
it could interfere with his first
responders
one or two people with guns - six or
seven people with guns without us having
insurance who's the good guy or bad guy
from that in some versions of what we're
doing will work the Shelby County
Sheriff tells Fox News he developed the
plan while watching Sandy Hook unfold
knowing his schools were not prepared we
cannot depend on the state or federal
government we can't depend on
psychologists to figure out why people
hurt one another the city middle schools
armed security guard says each staff
member went through intense training and
he considers them certified backup in a
minute there's a long time sometimes in
a situation where you're dealing with a
with a active killer as the national
debate rages on over whether teachers
and staff should be armed - the city
school district here in Ohio says it
stands by its decision
of one critical factor a quicker
response time in case of an active
shooter Brett
Matt thank you